je crois que nous avons assisté à
l'apothéose des grands médias qui ont
trouvé leur véritable fonction nous
avons eu le sacre de cléricalisme
médiatique
pourrait-on dire ouh là le rôle de
directeur de conscience des gens qui
sont supposés de nous un ferme et a pu
s'épanouir en toute liberté et avec une
écrasante faculté de se faire entendre
parce que tout le monde était un peu
rivés aux nouvelles donc la situation
était idéale pour les grands médias pour
la télévision au premier chef évidemment
une cause compassionnel qui existe des
bons sentiments qui suscite une émotion
profonde et qui est consensuelle qui
seules de très mauvais coucheurs pouvait
s'opposer à cette comptabilité mortuaire
quotidienne qui était devenu notre dette
messe quotidienne on a beaucoup parlé
des soignantes ont applaudi à 20h mais
le soignant qu'on applaudit à 20 heures
étaient en général précédée par une
sorte de rite préalables qui étaient là
l'énumération des morts de la journée
qui donnait tout son relief aux
applaudissements qui suivait donc on a
retrouvé vraiment une sorte de grand
messe qui donnant aux journalistes un
rôle dans la société qui n'ont jamais su
[Musique]